Générique
...
-Plus de la moitié des Français
a eu mal au dos
au moins une fois
au cours des 12 derniers mois.
Pourtant, ces douleurs
font encore l'objet d'idées reçues.
45 % des Français
considèrent par exemple
que le meilleur remède
est le repos.
-Paradoxalement, les pompes,
que j'aurais jamais imaginé
être un mouvement
qui pouvait soulager mes douleurs,
m'aident petit à petit.
-Les mauvais réflexes
augmentent le risque
de voir les douleurs s'installer
et devenir chroniques.
Pour les médecins,
il est donc nécessaire
d'aborder ce mal du siècle
dans toute sa complexité
afin de mieux le prendre en charge.
-On peut pas dire des choses
comme "j'ai entre 45 et 60 ans,
"j'ai mal au dos à telle hauteur,
ça me fait mal,
"et donc, pour tout le monde,
on va d'abord faire ça,
"et si ça marche pas,
on m'opère."
Ces choses-là n'existent pas
en douleur du dos.
En fait, le traitement se guide
de manière très personnalisée.
-"Mal de dos :
halte aux idées reçues",
c'est le thème de ce nouveau numéro
d'"Etat de santé".
-Bonjour et bienvenue
dans "Etat de santé"
consacré au fameux mal du siècle,
le mal de dos.
Il y a 1001 façons de souffrir :
physiques, psychologiques,
des vertèbres déplacées,
des douleurs lombaires,
un tour de reins...
Autant éviter les idées reçues.
Bonjour, Aurore Mambriani.
-Bonjour.
-On va les passer en revue.
Tout le monde a des histoires
de mal de dos, dans sa vie.
Vous êtes kiné.
Je parlais par exemple
de vertèbres déplacées.
Est-ce que ça,
c'est une appellation,
une formulation
qui est conforme à la réalité ?
-Pas vraiment.
On peut pas dire ça.
Les vertèbres ne se déplacent pas,
ou alors, quand elles se déplacent,
c'est très grave
et c'est une urgence.
Mais quand on va
chez le kinésithérapeute
et qu'on a mal au dos,
c'est rarement une vertèbre
qui est déplacée.
-Certaines personnes
qui se font manipuler
entendent bien des os,
que ce soit des vertèbres,
d'ailleurs,
ou d'autres éléments du dos,
qui font...
Pardon, je sais pas
comment le dire.
Ca fait crac.
Donc on se dit : "Il a replacé
la vertèbre ou la cervicale."
C'est pas ça ?
-C'est pas une vertèbre
qui est replacée.
C'est un phénomène de cavitation.
Il y a du gaz dans l'articulation
et on peut écarter
les surfaces articulaires,
et on a une bulle de gaz
qui se déplace,
qui fait un petit plop,
qui est perceptible...
-Le crac, c'est un plop ?
-C'est plutôt un plop
qu'un crac, oui.
-Et donc,
pourquoi c'est important
de bien nommer les choses ?
-C'est important
que les patients
n'aient pas de faux schémas
dans la tête.
En fait, ça peut amener
des croyances sur la gravité
et les enfermer aussi eux-mêmes
dans un cercle vicieux.
Le fait d'avoir peur,
ils vont limiter
leurs mouvements,
et cette peur de bouger,
ça peut être un facteur
de chronicisation,
notamment
sur les douleurs lombaires.
-C'est important
de passer en revue les idées reçues.
On va tout de suite regarder
votre parcours.
-Aurore Mambriani
est kinésithérapeute.
Elle est la présidente en France
de l'association OMT,
qui regroupe des kinés
spécialisés
dans la rééducation
des troubles musculo-squelettiques
comme les lombalgies.
Des troubles qu'Aurore Mambriani
connaît particulièrement bien
car elle a exercé pendant 10 ans
dans son cabinet libéral
en Haute-Marne
auprès d'une patientèle
ouvrière et agricole.
-Aurore Mambriani,
il y a plein de noms
pour qualifier
le mal de dos.
Y a-t-il un terme générique ?
La lombalgie, est-ce que ça concerne
toutes les douleurs de dos ?
-Non, la lombalgie,
c'est pour la région lombaire.
-Donc le bas du dos.
-Oui. Ensuite, on a les régions
thoracique, cervicale.
On peut avoir la lombalgie,
la cervicalgie.
C'est ce qu'on a
de plus commun
sur le mal de dos.
A part dire "douleurs"
ou "maux de dos",
c'est difficile parce que
si on utilise d'autres termes,
on induit d'autres choses,
des causes ou des conséquences.
On peut dire qu'on a
des maux de dos...
-Et demander à son kiné,
par exemple,
de savoir exactement de quoi...
-De quoi il en retourne.
-...il s'agit.
Deuxième idée reçue,
très importante,
c'est que
quand on a mal au dos,
on s'immobilise, on s'allonge
et on se dit que ça ira mieux.
C'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est
extraordinairement répandu.
Est-ce qu'on a raison ?
-Alors, si on a
des grosses douleurs de dos,
sûrement qu'il y a
plusieurs facteurs
qui jouent.
Il peut y avoir
un facteur de fatigue,
donc si on est fatigué,
il faut se reposer,
mais pour la douleur de dos,
le repos ne va pas
améliorer les choses.
C'est-à-dire qu'au-delà
d'un jour ou deux de repos,
c'est déconseillé,
et il faut reprendre les activités.
Donc ce qu'on disait avant,
"il faut rester trois mois alité",
ça empire.
Ca amène un enraidissement
articulaire, les muscles
vont être moins actifs,
donc ça veut dire que le travail
pour reprendre une activité normale
va être plus long.
Donc un à deux jours de repos,
mais pas plus.
-On en reparlera
avec le reportage.
Troisième idée reçue :
porter des charges lourdes,
ça donne mal au dos.
Vrai ou faux ?
-Tout est une question de contexte,
mais chez quelqu'un
qui est entraîné,
il y a pas de raison
que ça fasse mal au dos.
-Entraîné, c'est-à-dire ?
-Si vous demandez à quelqu'un
qui n'a jamais couru
de faire un marathon
du jour au lendemain,
il va avoir mal partout.
Quelqu'un qui ne porte jamais
de charges lourdes,
si vous lui demandez
de faire un déménagement,
ça va être compliqué.
Mais quelqu'un
qui a l'habitude de faire ça,
ça va pas lui poser de problème.
-Néanmoins,
la question du travail
facteur de mal de dos
est quand même une question
très présente
dans le monde professionnel.
C'est un enjeu de santé publique.
La preuve en quelques chiffres.
Infographie.
-Le mal de dos au travail,
presque tout le monde connaît ça.
En France, plus de 4 actifs sur 5
déclarent en avoir déjà souffert.
Et mal prévenir les lombalgies
a un coût important pour la société.
Arrêtons-nous donc sur ces chiffres.
Le mal de dos représente 20 %
des accidents du travail
et des maladies professionnelles
et un tiers des arrêts de travail
de plus de six mois.
En 2017, par exemple,
12 millions de journées de travail
ont ainsi été perdues,
soit un coût de 661 millions d'euros
pour l'Assurance maladie
et plus d'1 milliard d'euros
supporté par les entreprises
sous forme de cotisations.
Une étude suédoise a montré
que 85 % du coût
de la lombalgie chronique
par patient
était lié à cette perte
de productivité au travail,
concluant
qu'une meilleure prise en charge
permet de faire des économies,
même avec les traitements
les plus coûteux.
Quant aux employeurs,
en font-ils assez ?
69 % des salariés français
ont le sentiment
d'être mal accompagnés
dans la prévention du mal de dos.
Les actions
menées jusqu'à maintenant
n'ont pas fait baisser la fréquence
ni la durée des arrêts de travail.
Les formes chroniques,
qui sont les plus invalidantes,
ont même plutôt tendance
à augmenter.
-Aurore Mambriani, on passe en revue
toutes les idées reçues
relatives au mal de dos.
On dit souvent
que c'est psychologique :
"Parce que tu es nerveux,
parce que tu es stressé."
Le stress est un énorme facteur
de mal de dos, donc on dit :
"Qu'est-ce qui va pas dans ta tête
pour que tu aies mal au dos ?"
C'est une question pertinente ?
-Il faut connaître
tous les déterminants qui jouent
sur le mal de dos
de la personne.
Le stress
peut être un facteur,
comme le fait d'être contrarié
par une situation conflictuelle
au travail,
ou dans le cercle familial,
ou dans un cercle amical.
Tout ça peut jouer
sur le mal de dos.
-Il faut aller chez le psy ?
-Les kinés peuvent savoir détecter
quelle est cette part psychologique
et réorienter vers quelqu'un,
mais souvent,
il n'y a pas qu'un facteur.
Donc ce qui est intéressant,
c'est d'avoir une approche
pluriprofessionnelle :
on voit le kiné
pour certaines choses,
le psychologue
pour d'autres choses,
parfois on voit
une assistante sociale,
un nutritionniste
ou un professeur de sport
qui va travailler
sur des exercices
plus spécifiques.
-Justement,
un professeur de sport
qui fait bouger son patient
quand il a mal au dos,
c'est contre-intuitif,
comme on dit.
On ne pensait pas à cela
il y a quelques dizaines d'années,
au contraire.
Comment le mouvement
peut-il soulager les douleurs ?
Reportage, Marianne Cazaux.
-Contrairement à une idée reçue
encore très répandue,
face au mal de dos,
il faut bouger.
-Salut, Etienne.
-Depuis qu'il est suivi
dans ce cabinet
de kinésithérapie pour sa lombalgie,
Etienne Marchal l'a bien compris.
-OK, alors donc, tu m'as dit
que t'as réussi à faire
tout ce qu'on avait convenu ?
-Oui, un peu plus.
-Il n'avait jamais été
autant encouragé à bouger
pour soulager ses douleurs.
-Je sens
que les pompes, que j'aurais jamais
imaginé être un mouvement
qui pouvait m'aider, m'aident,
et j'ai du mal à comprendre
la mécanique.
-Si je prends ton coude
et que je te laisse trois heures,
qu'est-ce qui va se passer ?
-Je vais être endolori, ankylosé.
-Ca va s'ankyloser,
et qu'est-ce que tu vas
vouloir faire ?
Tu vas vouloir le tendre.
Il y a un peu ce côté-là
avec le dos,
c'est-à-dire que se tirer
vers l'arrière,
se grandir ou autre, c'est pas
quelque chose qu'on fait souvent.
On a tendance à être comme ça,
surtout devant l'ordi.
-Pendant ses longs mois de douleur,
Etienne Marchal a peu sollicité
ses muscles dorsaux,
qu'il renforce aujourd'hui.
Et même ces mouvements
qui ne ciblent pas le dos
ont un impact
sur la lombalgie.
-Je relève en montant ?
-Et tu changes.
-Etienne Marchal pourra
les refaire chez lui.
-La douleur est un signal
d'alarme.
Si tu mets la main
sur le feu, l'alarme va te dire
que tu vas te brûler.
Le signal d'alarme peut se régler :
plus ou moins sensible.
Et plus il est réglé sensible,
plus la douleur peut
se déclencher facilement
pour des trucs anodins.
L'activité physique est un
des excellents moyens
qu'on a qui permet de régler
à nouveau le signal.
-A l'inverse,
trop de repos
augmente le risque
de voir les douleurs s'installer.
C'est ce qui est arrivé
à Sylvie Bouchard.
Après une chute en VTT,
elle est restée près de 20 ans
immobilisée dans un corset
pour traiter
sa lombalgie chronique.
Elle pensait ne jamais pouvoir
remonter sur un vélo.
-A l'époque, il existait pas
les programmes dont vous bénéficiez,
de réentraînement à l'effort.
C'était le contraire
qui était recommandé :
le repos strict.
En 2010, j'en pouvais plus,
psychologiquement.
C'était très difficile,
20 ans alitée.
Ca a été très difficile sur le plan
socio-familial,
sur tous les plans de la vie.
-A force de persévérance
et de patience,
elle s'est remise à bouger,
à nager, et enfin, à pédaler.
-Les médecins n'avaient plus rien
à me proposer,
donc j'avais pas le choix
que de me prendre en main
et de me remuscler petit à petit
au travers de la douleur.
Ca a duré trois ans, c'était long,
mais j'y suis arrivée.
Je vais mieux,
je prends plus de médicament,
je suis plus immobilisée.
C'est un message d'espoir
que je leur fais passer.
-Pour éviter à d'autres
patients d'affronter
seul une telle épreuve,
Sylvie Bouchard a rejoint
l'équipe de ce programme
en tant que patiente experte,
un diplôme qu'elle a passé
afin de faire
valoir sa connaissance
de la lombalgie chronique.
C'est le docteur Chaleat-Valayer
qui coordonne le programme.
-Bonjour.
-Allez-y, entrez.
-Les patients arrivent souvent
dans ce centre de rééducation après
plusieurs années de douleur,
de mise au repos
et d'échec thérapeutique.
-"Je vais jamais m'en sortir."
-Vous avez essayé trop de choses.
-C'est ça, on passe
de mains en mains :
"Vous êtes un cas difficile.
"Je sais pas quoi faire."
Mais qui va pouvoir faire
quelque chose ?
-C'est pour ça qu'il faut
cette équipe pluridisciplinaire
qui va vous aider à avancer.
-Les patients comme Frédéric Vattier
suivent ici un réentraînement
à l'effort intensif
de quatre semaines.
Une nécessité, car à force
d'éviter de bouger
par crainte d'avoir mal,
ils ont perdu beaucoup de muscle.
Et le mouvement,
ce n'est pas
que l'exercice physique mais aussi
des activités du quotidien
qu'il faut
progressivement reprendre.
-Maintenant, enfournez.
-Avec l'ergothérapeute du centre,
Céline Nardi peut maintenant
effectuer ces gestes
qu'elle ne faisait plus.
-Voilà, peut-être !
Là, il y a pas la grille.
Bah voilà, c'est pas mal, ça.
-Oui.
-Vous avez encadré la porte.
Vous êtes pas de face.
-Oui, pas de face.
J'aime beaucoup faire la pâtisserie
avec mes enfants,
et tout ce qui était atelier
pâtisserie, je ne les faisais plus.
Ca impacte la vie familiale.
Il y a plein de choses
qu'on ne peut plus faire,
qu'on s'interdit
parce qu'il y a la douleur.
Et pour se remettre en route
toute seule, c'est pas possible.
-Ici, bien accompagnée,
elle retrouve son autonomie
et la force de sortir
du cercle vicieux de la douleur,
tout ça avec le mouvement.
-Est-ce qu'il y a encore
beaucoup de patients
qui sont étonnés
si vous leur demandez
de faire du sport
alors qu'ils ont mal au dos ?
-Beaucoup de patients
viennent en pensant
avoir une autre réponse.
On parle pas forcément de sport.
Faire du sport,
on a l'idée de transpirer,
de choses un peu difficiles.
Et en plus,
des fois, les gens
se retrouvent plus
dans le fait d'avoir
une activité simple,
qui s'apparente pas à du sport.
Le jardinage,
ça peut être une activité.
-On ne doit pas
s'interdire si on a mal au dos ?
-C'est ça.
-Idée reçue :
la natation,
c'est bon
pour le dos.
-C'est bon chez les gens
qui aiment la natation.
-Donc c'est bon
pour le dos ?
-Ca peut être bon pour les gens
qui aiment la natation.
Ceux qui n'aiment pas, il faut leur
dire que c'est bon pour leur dos.
Ils vont y aller
une fois sous la contrainte,
mais ils aiment pas y aller.
Et ils vont pas y retourner.
Ce qu'on cherche,
c'est que les gens bougent
un petit peu plus.
Quand on propose une activité,
on demande aux gens
ce qu'ils aiment faire.
L'idée est de le garder
dans le temps.
-Autre idée reçue : il faut
se tenir droit pour avoir moins mal.
-Ce qui est embêtant,
c'est que c'est le "tiens-toi droit"
qu'on dit aux adolescents.
Les ados sont un peu comme ça.
-Avachis, on dit.
-C'est ça, et on leur dit :
"Tiens-toi droit."
Donc ils se redressent
dans une position
qu'ils ne prennent jamais.
Leur corps n'a pas l'habitude.
Ils le font vite et leurs muscles
ne sont pas entraînés.
Donc ils vont dire :
"Si je me tiens droit,
"ça me fait mal,
je suis mieux comme ça."
Donc pour des adolescents,
ce qui est important, c'est que
dans un autre moment de la semaine,
il y ait d'autres activités,
du basket, du volley
ou une activité physique
qui fait que leur dos
va prendre les autres positions
et les emmagasiner
autant que la position en avant.
-Donc ne pas forcément dire :
"Tiens-toi droit." ?
-Plutôt que de le dire à ses enfants
parce qu'ils restent dans le canapé,
il vaut mieux les envoyer dehors.
-Intéressant, cette approche globale
que vous avez.
Autre question.
On a une jambe plus longue,
des pieds plats, on est cambré...
C'est pour ça qu'on a mal ?
-Non.
-Non ?
On a tous
une différence
d'à peu près 1 ou 1,5 cm
des jambes.
Ca ne pose aucun souci.
Et les pieds plat
ou le dos cambré,
en fait, on a un corps humain
qui s'adapte depuis la naissance,
donc sauf si on a les pieds plats
après un accident
ou un traumatisme
ou une cambrure de dos qui change
après un traumatisme,
le corps grandit comme ça.
Il y a pas de raison particulière.
-Je ne sais pas si c'était
une idée reçue
du corps médical pendant
des décennies,
mais longtemps, mal de dos,
répété, évidemment,
sur une longue distance,
sous-entendait une opération.
C'est un peu moins vrai.
Marianne Cazaux est allée à Lille
pour comprendre
dans quel contexte on prenait ou pas
la décision d'opérer.
Reportage.
-Dans 90 % des cas,
les douleurs lombaires
disparaissent d'elles-mêmes
au bout de quatre semaines.
Mais parfois,
elles persistent.
Une question se pose alors :
faut-il opérer ?
-Découverte fortuite d'une ectasie
de l'aorte thoracique ascendante
à 38 mm
pour moins de 5 mm d'épaisseur.
Il n'y a pas d'indication
à une réévaluation systématique
par imagerie, conformément
aux recommandations actuelles.
-Une question à laquelle
Jean-François Budzik
n'aime pas répondre, car
à la différence de cette pathologie
cardiovasculaire,
les lombalgies sont complexes.
-On peut pas dire des choses comme :
"J'ai entre 45 et 60 ans,
j'ai mal au dos à telle hauteur,
"et ça me fait mal en bas,
"donc pour tout le monde,
on va faire ça,
"et si ça marche pas, on m'opère."
Ca n'existe pas en douleur du dos,
et le traitement se guide
de manière très personnalisée.
-Avec ces douleurs si particulières,
le radiologue a appris
à ne pas toujours
se fier à l'imagerie pour choisir
un traitement adapté.
Prenons l'exemple de cette patiente
pour laquelle il a enquêté.
-Une dame qui a 80 ans
qui fait un certain type
d'infiltration de la colonne
pour un canal lombaire rétrécit.
-Autrement dit :
ses nerfs sont serrés
au niveau de la colonne vertébrale,
comme le prouve cette image.
Une pathologie qui se manifeste
par des douleurs nerveuses
dans les jambes.
Mais dans ce cas précis...
-Elle a mal au dos mais n'a pas
de douleur dans les jambes,
ce qui montre que l'image,
même si elle est impressionnante,
n'est pas la cause.
Le traitement peut se concentrer
là-dessus et tomber en échec
puisqu'il est probable
que l'infiltration des nerfs
n'a pas grand intérêt, mais
avec une approche personnalisée,
on revoit les images,
on adapte les choses autrement
en allant chercher le coupable,
qui est à côté du suspect principal,
qui pour le coup
est complètement innocent.
-Ne s'intéresser
qu'à l'imagerie médicale
peut donc induire en erreur.
Il faut un interrogatoire fouillé
pour trouver le traitement adéquat.
-C'est plutôt ici, devant,
sur le côté, derrière ?
-Non, derrière, c'est plus rare.
Devant ou sur le côté.
-Vous faites quoi, dans la vie ?
-Je suis ouvrière textile.
-Très bien.
Vous êtes amenée
à rester debout ?
-Oui, 8 heures.
-Et à porter des charges lourdes ?
-Oui.
-Qu'attendez-vous
du traitement,
du point de vue des douleurs ?
-En fait, chaque jour, j'ai mal,
mais il y a des moments
où je souffre terriblement,
à en pleurer.
Si déjà ça pouvait s'atténuer...
Même limite avoir mal,
mais ne plus souffrir.
-Le choix du traitement
ne dépend pas de la lésion,
mais des attentes des patients.
Jean-François Budzik propose
des alternatives à la chirurgie,
comme la radiologie
interventionnelle.
Elle se fait au bloc,
mais elle est très peu invasive.
-La patiente est positionnée.
On va ensuite, sur le repérage,
trouver la zone
et puis on va trouver
une zone sécurisée.
Il y a de la peau
et des muscles à traverser.
C'est pas très dur.
Et on va raisonner aussi
en fonction
des petites terminaisons nerveuses
pour trouver l'approche
la plus pertinente.
-La radiologie permet
de cibler la douleur
de la manière
la plus précise possible.
Jean-François Budzik injecte
un anesthésique local,
puis un produit de contraste
qu'il peut suivre à l'imagerie.
-Voilà.
Le produit a bien diffusé
dans l'espace autour.
Voilà, il circonscrit exactement...
-Une fois la zone identifiée,
l'infiltration
de produits corticoïdes
est prête.
-Voilà, c'est terminé.
Voilà, on va laisser infuser.
-Si cela ne suffit pas à apaiser
durablement la douleur,
le radiologue pourra s'y attaquer
en chauffant les nerfs
par radiofréquence.
Et pour chaque intervention,
ce n'est pas la lésion
qui est ciblée.
-L'information naît
dans l'articulation,
mais c'est le cerveau
qui intègre ça
et qui crée l'information
de douleur. Donc, l'idée, ici,
c'est de ne pas forcément
aller chercher
par exemple une articulation,
mais de s'intéresser au symptôme
qui pose problème : la douleur.
-Si la cause du mal de dos
est clairement mécanique,
la chirurgie peut être
une bonne solution,
mais elle est rarement nécessaire.
-Alors, Aurore Mambriani,
c'est vrai
qu'il y a beaucoup de patients
qu'on voulait opérer,
et on l'a vu dans le reportage,
il y a des alternatives
à l'opération.
C'est un progrès ?
-Euh, oui.
On peut dire ça.
La médecine s'est conçue
sur un abord de la maladie.
Mais la lombalgie,
c'est pas une maladie,
c'est pas une tumeur.
-C'est quoi ?
-C'est une affliction,
on peut dire...
-Oui ?
-Mais c'est pas un truc
qu'il faudrait enlever,
d'où la chirurgie.
La médecine,
elle se dit : "Si le patient a mal,
quelque chose dysfonctionne
"dans le corps du patient."
On sait qu'on peut avoir
des douleurs et des afflictions
sans qu'il y ait quelque chose
qui dysfonctionne,
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
d'autres facteurs qui jouent autour
et qui peuvent se manifester
par des symptômes physiques
ou des choses dans le cerveau.
-Passons des idées reçues
à la réalité
de votre pratique médicale.
Evidemment,
comme pour beaucoup
de rendez-vous médicaux,
c'est très long,
d'avoir un rendez-vous chez le kiné,
et il y a une volonté du législateur
pour qu'on puisse aller chez le kiné
sans passer par un généraliste.
C'est pas une idée reçue.
C'est une mesure
qui a été adoptée.
On le verra dans un instant.
Vous avez voulu
interroger un député
sur cette question
de l'application de la loi.
Stéphanie Rist,
députée Renaissance du Loiret,
est l'auteure
de cette proposition de loi.
Votre question :
"A quel moment pensez-vous
que la loi pourra être appliquée ?
"S'agit-il d'une première étape
"vers un élargissement
de la disposition ?"
Elle vous répond.
-Cette loi a été votée au printemps.
Les décrets
devraient sortir prochainement.
J'espère avant la fin
de l'année.
J'aimerais qu'on soit allés
un peu plus vite,
mais tous les kinésithérapeutes
qui travaillent
en exercice de soins coordonnés
dans les maisons de santé,
dans les centres de santé...
Les malades pourront aller
directement voir ces kinés.
Il existe une expérimentation
dans certains départements
pour ouvrir
à plus de kinésithérapeutes.
Une fois que les patients
et les professionnels verront
que la sécurité du malade se fait
sans aucun problème,
on pourra discuter
d'un élargissement
à tous les kinésithérapeutes.
Mais l'important est quand même
de garder le soin coordonné.
Il faut respecter
le parcours du patient.
Il faut travailler ensemble.
C'est vraiment majeur sur la qualité
de prise en charge des malades.
-La loi,
quand elle sera appliquée,
ne concernera
qu'une petite partie des médecins.
Vous parlez de 3 %.
Vous voudriez
que ce soit tout le monde ?
-Pour les patients,
ce serait bien que l'élargissement
soit plus important,
effectivement.
Cet accès direct,
on le fait déjà.
Quand on suit un patient
pour une lombalgie
et qu'il vient nous voir le lundi
en nous disant :
"Le dos, ça va,
"mais je me suis fait mal
au poignet, ce week-end",
en fait, souvent, on regarde.
C'est aussi de l'accès direct.
-Passionnant de vous avoir entendue.
Vous avez remis
certaines idées en place.
La dernière, en conclusion,
est très légère.
Quoique !
Porter des talons,
ça fait mal au dos ?
-Quand vous allez à un mariage,
si vous mettez des grands talons,
que vous n'avez pas l'habitude,
on sait ce qui se passe.
-La chute, déjà.
-C'est un risque.
Au bout de 3 heures,
toutes les femmes ont enlevé
leurs talons
et elles dansent pieds nus
ou avec d'autres chaussures.
Donc en fait, le cerveau dit,
à un moment : "Je vais pas bien."
On a souvent mal aux pieds
avant d'avoir mal au dos.
Après, il y a des femmes
qui ont toujours porté des talons.
Si vous les mettez à plat,
elles vont pas être bien.
Il y a des femmes capables
de marcher très vite
avec des très hauts talons fins.
Leur corps s'est habitué comme ça.
Elles, elles aiment ça,
et elles n'ont pas forcément
mal au dos.
-Il n'y a pas
de modèle dans la façon
de traiter le mal de dos.
C'est ce que je retiens
de l'émission.
Il n'y a pas de modèle.
-On a affaire à de l'humain,
et c'est complexe.
-Merci infiniment
de nous avoir accompagnés.
-Bien sûr.
-Merci à tous de nous avoir suivis.
A très vite.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...